let's get all the crazy out of the way
uh so a bunch of people ask me since we
talked about the simulation last time
we talked about hacking the simulation
do you have any updates
any insights about how we might be able
to go about
hacking simulation if we indeed do live
in a simulation
i think a lot of people misinterpreted
the point of that south by talk
um the point of the south by talk was
not literally to hack the simulation
uh i think that this
we this is this is an idea is literally
just i think theoretical physics i think
that's
the whole you know the whole
goal right you want your grand unified
theory but then okay
build a grand u5 theory search for
exploits right i think we're nowhere
near actually there
yet my hope with that was just more to
like
like are you people kidding me with the
things you spend time thinking about
do you understand like kind of how small
you are
you are you are bites and god's computer
really and the things that people get
worked up about and
you know so basically it was more
a message of uh we should humble
ourselves
that we get to uh like
what what are we humans in this bite
code
yeah and not just not just humble
ourselves but like
like i'm not trying to like make you
feel guilty or anything like that i'm
trying to say like literally
look at what you are spending time on
right what are you referring to you're
referring to the kardashians what are we
talking about
from twitter to no the kardashians see
everyone knows that's kind of
fun i'm referring more to like the
economy
you know this idea that
we gotta up our stock price like
or or what is what is the goal function
of humanity you don't like the game of
capitalism
like you don't like the games we've
constructed for ourselves as humans
i'm a big fan of of capitalism i don't
think that's really the game we're
playing right now i think we're playing
a
a different game where the rules are
rigged
look at which games are interesting to
you that we humans have constructed and
which aren't
which are productive and which
are not actually maybe that's the real
point of the
of the talk it's like stop playing these
fake human games there's a real game
here
we can play the real game the real game
is you know nature wrote the rules
this is a real game there still is a
game to play
but if you look at sergeant drop i don't
know if you've seen the instagram
account nature is metal
the game that nature seems to be playing
is a lot
a lot more cruel that we humans want to
put up with or at least we see it as
cool it's like
the bigger thing eats the smaller thing
and uh does it to impress another
big thing so it can mate with that thing
and that's it that seems to be the
entirety of it
well there's no art there's no music
there's no comma ai there's no comma one
no comma two no george
hotz with his brilliant talks at south
by southwest
see i disagree though i disagree that
this is what nature is i think nature
just provided basically a uh
open world mmorpg and um
you know here it's open world i mean if
that's the game you want to play you can
play that game
isn't that isn't that beautiful i know
if you play diablo they used to have uh
i think cow level
where it's
uh so everybody will go just they
figured out this
like the best way to gain like
experience points
is to just slaughter cows over and over
and over
and uh so they figured out this little
sub game within the bigger game that
this is the most efficient way
to get experience points and everybody
somehow agreed that getting experience
points in
rpg contacts where you always want to be
getting more stuff
more skills more levels keep advancing
that seems to be good
so might as well spend sacrifice
actual enjoyment of playing a game
exploring a world
and spending like hundreds of hours of
your time
in cow level i mean the number of hours
i spent in cow level
i'm not like the most impressive person
because people spend probably thousands
of hours there but it's ridiculous
so that's a little absurd game that
brought me joy in some weird dopamine
drug
kind of way yeah so you don't like those
games you don't
you don't think that's us humans failing
the
the yeah nature i think so and that was
the point of the talk
yeah so how do we hack it then well i
want to live forever
and wait i want to live forever
and this is like the goal well that's a
game against nature
yeah immortality is the good objective
function to you
i mean start there and then you can do
whatever else you want because you've
got a long time
water for mortality makes the game just
totally not fun
i mean like why do you assume
immortality
is uh somehow uh it's not
a good objective function it's not
immortality that i want
a true immortality where i could not die
i would prefer what we have right now
um but i want to choose my own death of
course
i don't want nature to decide when i die
i'm going to win i'm going to be you
and then at some point if you choose
commit suicide
like how long you think you'd live
until i get bored see i don't think
people
like in like brilliant people like you
that really ponder
living a long time are really
considering
how how meaningless life becomes
well i want to know everything and then
i'm ready to die
as long as why do you want isn't it
possible that you want to know
everything because
it's finite like the reason you want to
know
quote-unquote everything is because you
don't have enough time to
know everything and once you have
unlimited time then you realize like
why do anything like why
learn anything i want to know everything
and then i'm ready to die
so you have yeah it's a terminal value
it's not
it's not in service of anything else i'm
conscious of the possibility this is not
a certainty
but the possibility is of that engine of
curiosity that you're speaking to
is actually a
a symptom of uh the finiteness of life
like
without that finiteness
your curiosity would vanish like like a
like a morning fog
all right cool that's he talked about
love like that then um
let me solve immortality let me change
the thing in my brain that reminds me of
the fact that i'm immortal tells me that
life is finite maybe i'll have it
tell me that life ends next week
right i'm okay with some self
manipulation like that i'm okay with
with deceiving oh change oh rico
changing the code if that's the problem
right if the problem is that i will no
longer have that
that curiosity i'd like to have backup
copies of myself
uh which i've yeah well which i check in
with occasionally to make sure they're
okay with the trajectory and they can
kind of override it
maybe a nice like i think of like those
wavenet so it's like logarithmic go back
to the copies
but sometimes it's not reversible like
uh sure i've done this with video
games when once you figure out the cheat
code or like you look up how to cheat
old school like single player it ruins
the game for you absolutely i know that
feeling but again
that just means our brain manipulation
technology is not good enough yet remove
that cheat code from your brain
what if we all so it's also possible
that if we figure out immortality
that all of us will kill ourselves
before we advance
far enough to uh to be able to revert
the change
i'm not killing myself until i know
everything so that's what you say now
because
your life is finite you know i think yes
self-modifying systems
gets comes up with all these hairy
complexities and can i promise that i'll
do it perfectly no but i think i can put
good safety structures in place
you